major layoffs Silicon Valley is on a
fighting Street for 11
000 planned job cuts at meta about yet
another tech company conducting these
Mass layoffs tech industry could expect
more layoffs for another three to six
months
[Music]
by now you've probably heard about the
tech perch stripe cut 1100 jobs coinbase
cut 1100 jobs Shopify cut a thousand
jobs Snapchat cut a thousand jobs Robin
Hood laid off a third of their staff
Tesla laid off a tenth of their salaried
staff and The Meta laid off a whopping
11 000 employees and those are just the
companies that have already resorted to
layoffs while the remaining big tech
companies haven't started laying off
people yet they have pulled back on
hiring substantially Apple Google
Microsoft Uber lived Nvidia Intel ended
many more all have hiring freezes in
place now you can't feel too bad for
these employees because it's not the
same as blue collar workers being laid
off most of these guys were earning High
200s if not more and were on track to
becoming Deca millionaires so it's not
like they'll be struggling to get by
what may be difficult however is scoring
another job with the same compensation
with all of Silicon Valley pulling back
many any of these guys will be forced to
find the jobs app background companies
like at T or Texas Instruments well
these companies will still pay
generously in relation to what the
average American earns the total
compensation will be nowhere near what
Silicon Valley offered for example the
highest paid software engineers at at T
earn 145 000 per year which is not a bad
amount but the highest paid software
engineers at Facebook earn 1.82 million
dollars per year even the entry level at
Facebook is 23 000 higher than the best
level at A T also these background
companies will probably be hesitant when
it comes to extending job offers to
these laid off employees not because
they're not qualified but because they
definitely won't be loyal everyone knows
that these guys will switch back to
Silicon Valley as soon as it becomes
viable so it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to hire someone that you know will
probably be gone in two years and the
main reason for this is simply how
absurd Silicon Valley compensations have
gotten so how did these compensations
get so high and what we see Fang ever
return to paying these salaries
at first glance it's easy to write off
Fang's massive salaries as a result of
their profitability these companies
often have profit margins of 30 or 40
percent so they're able to pay rather
High salaries and still make a bunch of
money and while this does play a role in
fangs compensation it's by far the
smallest Factor the main factor allowing
for such compensation is actually the
exponential growth of these companies if
you take a closer look at the fan
compensation you'll see that the vast
majority comes from stock based
compensation and that their base
salaries aren't actually all that crazy
product directors get paid a 1.34
million dollars per year but only 325
000 of that is actually base salary
product directors at Fang are equivalent
to vice presidents at non-fan companies
like Exon and you wouldn't be that
surprised to hear that Exxon BP is
making 300 to 500 000 per year so if
we're just looking at base salaries fan
companies aren't actually all that
different from non-fang companies the
real difference is that on top of this
you get paid 898 000 in stock at
Facebook now there's a few good reasons
that Fang does this first of all if your
employees own stock they'll be far more
motivated to help the company make more
money and secondly stock compensation
generally comes with investing periods
of four years meaning that employees
have to stick around for at least four
years to redeem all of your stock so
this kind of locks them in for a bit
insiders like to call this the golden
handcuffs but the main reason that so
much of the compensation comes from
stock is because that's the only way
these companies can afford to pay out
such salaries while these companies do
make a bunch of money even they wouldn't
be able to pay these salaries in cash
but wait a minute isn't stock
compensation the same thing don't
companies have to pay for the stock that
they award to their employees well yes
they do but not in the way that you
might think Facebook doesn't go onto the
stock market and buy 900 000 worth of
stocks so that they can pay a director
instead they simply die loot existing
shareholders and print new stock
Facebook for example had 87 000
employees before the layoffs if we
assume that the average Facebook
employee gets a hundred thousand dollars
worth of stock every year that works out
to a total stock compensation of 8.7
billion dollars per year if Facebook
paid this in cash I would wipe out a
third of your net income but when they
were worth a trillion dollars this
compensation was equivalent to less than
one percent shareholder dilution I think
you can see why the latter is far
preferred the only caveat is that these
companies have to continue growing
exponentially if these companies start
to stagnate or Worse start to sell off
shareholders will no longer be okay with
the dilution this is why stagnant
companies like Exxon and atnt can't
compete with Fang in terms of total
compensation while they're able to come
close in terms of cash compensation they
simply can't afford the same dilution
and speaking of dilution with how the
stocks of high-flying companies have
been performing and it's not clear if
Silicon Valley can afford such dilution
moving forward either
and no secret that the stock market has
been getting destroyed and host of this
Destruction has centered around Silicon
Valley a firm is down at 90 percent
Robin Hood is down at 80 Lyft is down at
83 percent Netflix is down 58 and even
Facebook is down 75 percent as these
companies sell off stock compensation
related dilution becomes more and more
expensive especially for new hires
remember the 8.7 billion that we
calculated for Facebook at a trillion
dollar evaluation that's less than one
percent dilution but at their current
300 billion valuation that's closer to
three percent dilution and where this
becomes really dangerous is if Facebook
it doesn't to grow for the next 10 years
from an outside perspective this
wouldn't be that bad after all 300
billion dollars is still a ginormous
valuation and Facebook would probably
still be making plenty of money but from
a shareholder perspective this would be
a disaster here's the thing three
percent dilution for 10 years it works
out to 30 total dilution this means that
if you had a hundred thousand dollar
stake in Facebook it would be worth
seventy thousand dollars by the end of
ten years even though the company itself
stayed stable factor in inflation and
your initial hundred thousand dollars
take is now worth closer to just fifty
thousand dollars I think you can see why
investors aren't exactly thrilled to
pick up these companies even though
they're down so much and honestly
looking forward it doesn't look too good
for any of the Silicon Valley Giants
Apple iPhone sales peaked years ago this
is why Apple stopped reporting how many
iPhones they sold it and started
increasing prices aggressively they were
able to continue growing profits thanks
to these price increases along with
Services Revenue but it looks like the
upside from these are starting to run
out not because apple is doing anything
wrong but simply because they've reached
Market saturation and it looks like it's
the same case with all of their Tech
peers as well out of the 4.72 billion
people have access to the internet 4.3
billion already use Google similarly
Instagram gram is about to reach 2.5
billion monthly active users and
WhatsApp is at 2.2 billion users how
many more people could realistically use
Google YouTube Netflix iCloud and Uber
the answer is not that many all these
companies are essentially Mega
monopolies that have already captured
the entire market and with advertisers
pulling back due to the recession these
companies will make less money even with
the stable user account and there's no
question that this will result in these
companies rethinking it just how much
they're paying their employees
foreign
so here's what we've established the
only reason that tech companies are able
to pay so much is because most of the
compensation is in the form of stock
which is paid for by stock dilution this
however only works when the company's
stocks are booming with these companies
reaching Market saturation along with
the economic uncertainty it's not clear
how much longer these companies can pay
these insane salaries and that brings us
to the crossroads that we're at today
these companies that really only have
two options with the first being
pivoting to a new industry with plenty
of growth left the company that's most
iconic for trying to do this is of
course Facebook they changed their
company's name to meta and they're
betting it all on the metaverse they're
literally looking to spend a hundred
billion dollars on this and while they
received a lot of criticism for this
there's no question that if they are
able to figure it out in the way that
they've envisioned it as opposed to how
it is right now it would truly be huge
this would likely be enough for MATA to
grow to a multi-trend on market cap if
not over 10 trillion dollars allowing
them to make their stock compensation
even more ludicrous another company who
is betting it all is Netflix Netflix is
turning around and spending all of their
earnings into in-house Productions
they're hoping that this will make them
more independent of Production Studios
and given that they spent 270 million
dollars on the most recent season of
stranger things they're clearly taking
this pretty seriously investors on the
other hand are scared of these massive
pivots and that's why these stocks are
down the most conversely some other Tech
Giants are choosing to play it safe and
are slowly becoming dividend stocks
likely the two best examples of this are
Apple and Microsoft unlike Google
Facebook Netflix and Amazon apple and
Microsoft already pay dividends and it
looks like they're simply going to lean
more into this these companies were
already on the lower end of fan
compensation at Apple for example even
the top level software Engineers were
only getting paid 607 37 000 per year
which is almost three times less than
the top engineers at Facebook as these
companies choose different paths moving
forward it appears that this discrepancy
will only grow larger
in the end with all these Tech layoffs
it appears that the ball is finally
shifting from the employee's side to the
employer's side thanks to the seemingly
unlimited VC funding and Hyper growth
associated with these companies
employees have been able to negotiate
salaries as high as seven figures but
with the economic downturn it and a
bunch of newly laid off Tech workers
looking for work it doesn't seem like
these numbers will fly anymore at least
not for some time in the meantime these
guys will probably have to take a
substantial pay cut and to join a
background company or maybe even start
their own company on the bright side
though I doubt that the recession is
going to wipe out any of these big Tech
names eventually they will get to the
other side and start hiring again but
when they do it the compensations will
probably look a lot different companies
that are choosing stability like apple
and Microsoft will likely be far less
generous when it comes to handing out
stock if they're embracing dividends
they can't also Embrace growth and
dilution on the other hand companies
like Facebook and startups like coinbase
will likely hand out more stock
compensation than ever but that of
course comes along with a bunch of
additional risk you're essentially
betting that the metaverse or whatever
product the company is pivoting to will
actually pan out so it appears that the
days of low risk High compensation are
quickly coming to an end but that's just
what I think do you think the metaverse
will pan out comment that down below
also drop a like if you wish Fang
salaries became the norm and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest future video ideas and
it consider subscribing to see more
questions answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign